- So we know you were acting,
but you're a singer as well.
- Oh, man.
- Did you start singing?
- I feel, this is kind of crazy for me
because you were one of the
reasons why I started singing.
- Wow.
- Was such a humongous fan,
and I was, I remember growing
up and seeing, you know,
that I'm here, I'm kind
of pinching myself.
But yes, I started when
I was really young,
and I would not tell you
that I'm a singer because
I'm like mediocre at first.
- Oh my gosh.
- But I did, and then I turned
into more of a acting career
throughout life, I think,
just eventually felt
like more of an organic choice for me.
But I did, I did start singing,
and I still love it, I still do.
- It's a great, I still call it a hobby.
Like I know I do it for work
- Yeah.
- But it's still like one
of my favorite things.
Like I sat on my peanut the
other day, like last weekend,
trying to like pat up this
song that I was writing,
and I was like, and there's nothing,
it still feels really good,
it feels like a hobby
and something fun to do
instead of a job.
So is still, yeah.
- It takes up
the pressure, right?
I feel like when I approach it
that way, I really enjoy it.
But when I'm like, "I
have to be a singer,"
like I it just caves me.
- Yeah.
No one should ever think
like that, ruin it.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Absolutely.